ça se passe en grande-bretagne tony et
tony et lorna un couple de britanniques
décident d'ouvrir leurs portes à une
réfugiée en détresse sofia ukrainienne
de 22 ans dépose donc ses valises chez
eux début mai oui mais voilà au bout de
dix jours tony quitte sa femme et ses
deux enfants pour retourner vivre chez
ses parents avec la jeune femme dont il
est tombé éperdument amoureux c'est le
sun qui rapporte cette histoire il a
peut-être pris un peu trop au sérieux
son rôle d'eric bergeron le de coco et
on va cueillir benjamin castaldi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans ce milieu professionnel tout le
monde fait semblant et vous aussi vous
faites semblant dans le milieu
professionnel marivaux 10 des acteurs
ils font semblant de faire semblant et
isabelle carré diviser le territoire
exactement et d'alléger dit ça c'est
très pratiquant le jeu des citations lé
jeudi si c'est peut-être aussi d'arrêter
de faire comme si ce que parfois vous
êtes dit rétrospectivement là
effectivement j'ai je me suis fait
prendre à ce jeu de la gloire de la
notoriété du pouvoir et est sans doute
ai-je manqué de la distance qu'il
convient d'avoir
écouté oui une question intime je pense
que je pense qu'à un moment le le
pouvoir ont un peu fou
et me ciré les pompes
mais bien sûr s'il est l'époux par un
trois étoiles le seul magique
vous êtes rarement costumes comme par
exemple la voilà ça c'est beau
travail et voir à quoi j'ai une autre
photo vous êtes un peu plus
[Applaudissements]
la joue bien voilà
on traîne dans la boue les gens qui
travaillent
c'est ça la société d'aujourd'hui mais
non mais j'ai même envie de fermer les
yeux tellement c'est matin
charline je me prévient quand c'est le
supplice est terminée elle lui dit j'ai
un aimant et un amant et et lui dit
aussi et ben là je suis regardé que vous
vous rendez compte ali ce que vous
faites à 25 ans exactement ce que fait
qu'ils avaient le carré vert que vous
répondez pas du tout la question et vous
vous cachez derrière des citations c'est
mal barré blier
alors c'est pratique on peut faire
toutes les c'est ça peut-être un
écrivain quelqu'un qui ne répond jamais
aux questions et qui se planque derrière
les démos des autres je me fais draguer
je vais vous dire un truc quand je suis
avec les artistes ce soit avec jean-luc
ou d'autres jeux tout soit fait sur
plusieurs que personnalités du showbiz
les gamines elles viennent me voir je
suis pas là avec une carte d'identité
bourse quand je vous dis un truc quand
j'étais gamin j'avais 20 ans j'en disais
vous le terrain vedette faut toucher la
bête voilà c'est comme ça que j'ai
réussi un oui quand même je faisais gas
ben oui mais marc dont je rêve à force
ce matin qr code sur la housse la foule
pour savoir avec qui on va comment fait
premier a priori une femme qui se plaint
ne mangez jamais
ça n'est pas un principe inscrit dans la
loi c'est un principe dit merci oui mais
attendez à ce que je peux pas rêver
l'isi parions sépare dont parle merci
beaucoup donc une femme ne ment jamais
il faut toujours la croire et deuxième
point qu parfaitement l'espèce que c'est
une réalité c'est trop bien
soit
tu vas bien méritée celle là quoi le
pique nique une chute et balle en l'air
en même temps donc
cactus deuxième principe qui est en
passe dans un domaine très particulier
d'être adoptée de faire office de loi
tout homme est un violeur en puissance
bon ce que tu déjà bon et ce qui est
exact en puissance violeur en puissance
bien sûr ah oui bon
bah non je vous fais un dessin non mais
je rêve
les feuilles mortes se ramassent à la
terre et les souvenirs et les regrets
aussi